We have a voicemail number two, one nine two
David p here is sometimes talking points just
spread like a virus and nobody actually examines
the content of them.
Here's one example about polling.
Take a listen.
Hey David, it's Josh from Virginia.
That was just a curious, I had heard that
a majority of the polls have for presidential
candidates are done over landlines.
And I was wondering does that give it a more
of an older voter, uh, uh, influence on those
polls or a majority of people in the younger
ages are having cell phones?
I wasn't sure.
I, I had heard that a majority of them were
done, done over land lines and I was just
curious on your take on that.
Anyway, thanks for your show.
It's awesome.
Keep up the good work.
So the general talking point is that polling
is very establishment centric because they
are oversampling older folks who are, who
tend to be more, uh, establishment or on the
right, even within the Democratic Party.
The older folks tend to be more establishment.
They're using landlines, which tends to be
more older folks than younger folks that have
them.
You've really got to look at it, pull by poll.
But generally speaking, this isn't the case
a, when I looked at a bunch of the recent
polls, most of them are sampling older folks
in proportion to their, uh, um, uh, representation
in the population adjusted slightly for the
fact that older folks are actually more likely
to go out and vote.
So you do need to adjust the sample slightly
on that basis.
The economist you Gov pulled that we talked
about earlier today, did not use landlines.
It was using web-based interviews.
I get calls on my mobile phone all the time
from the PR, from pollsters all the time.
I mean, you know, every few months or something
like that.
Uh, so no, it, you, you can look at the methodology
for each pole.
Um, and it, uh, I don't think it serves us
to criticize polls for reasons that aren't
good ones.
There are many ways in which we can add caveats
and nuance, our understanding of polling.
But there's a lot of people who just are saying
it's all fake because they use all landlines
and are polling mostly old people.
This just isn't true in general, and I encourage
you to look at the methodologies of polls
to confirm it for yourself.
Don't take my word for it.
I mean, really don't.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get access to the bonus show by becoming a
member or
a patron@joinpacman.com or patrion.com/david
Pack, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.